former independent counsel Ken Starr is
speaking out in detail for the first
time on CBS this morning about his
investigations and the impeachment of
President Bill Clinton Starr was
appointed in 1994 to look into a failed
real-estate deal in Arkansas known as
whitewater four years later he
investigated the president's affair with
White House intern Monica Lewinsky in
his new book contempt a memoir of the
Clinton investigation Starr writes quote
I deeply regret that I took on the
Lewinsky phase of the investigation but
at the same time as I still see it 20
years later there was no practical
alternative to doing so Ken Starr joins
us this morning good morning good
morning let's talk about that what parts
of the Lewinsky investigation do you
regret I regretted the whole thing but
it had to be done when the information
came to us that the President of the
United States may have been in the
process of committing perjury
obstructing justice we went to the
Attorney General of the United States
Janet Reno she agreed and so the rest is
all history that's what I try to do in
this book and let's remind people of
some of that history how did your office
get the tip about Monica Lewinsky it
came to us from a very well known
witness but in the Vince Foster death
investigation her name Linda trap Linda
was the last person in the White House
who we know to have seen Vince Foster
alive before he took his on life in Fort
Marcy Park and so she came to us with
this information that she was being
asked to file a perjury ridden affidavit
that's how it began but so when you hear
that a woman has information about an
alleged affair that the President and
you're investigating whitewater do you
say we don't need to investigate that
that's not relevant what was going
through your mind in terms of of
investigating in what was going through
our mind is we had seen this pattern
before let's find a job for another
character in the investigation web
Hubbell let's get him clients so that in
our view he would not cooperate fully
with our investigation it was the same
modus operandi we felt that the
president had not been truthful in the
Whitewater phase of the investigate
so it was the same pattern so you
started with a land deal whitewater and
it ended up all the way over at Monica
Lewinsky you as you've just outlined
we're following kind of the course of
events that they've happened when people
talk about the current special counsels
investigation they say well it started
to look into collusion but now it's
finding its way to other places is there
anything wrong with a prosecution that
starts in one place and ends up
somewhere else no there are eerie
similarities as what's happening now as
to what happened then you just don't
know what's going to come before you the
Kia's are there checks and balances to
make sure that the prosecutor isn't just
doing anything and everything the check
at the time was for me to go to the
Attorney General and for the Attorney
General to go to the special division of
the court and say this has to be
investigated the present United States
and this is what the book is all about
the president United States may be
committing crimes or perhaps has
committed crimes we've got to have a
check in a balance and that's what we
have in the Muller investigation so
president Trump's legal team is
considering whether he should sit down
for an interview with Robert Muller
do you think he should I think as the
president United States he should if I'm
a criminal defense lawyer I'm saying
don't do it it's theirs there's too
great a risk so it's a different
perspective my perspective as the
president itíd States has an obligation
to enforce and obey the law apply that
perspective to the idea that that
prosecutors might be setting up what do
Rudy Giuliani has called a perjury trap
for the president is that something
respectable prosecutors do and you think
that's what Robert Muller is doing
respectable prosecutors do not set up a
perjury trap they try to get the story
what what what's your version of the
story and it it may be a story that
conflicts with what another witness says
but I don't view that as a perjury trap
lawyers like that would Muller do that I
don't think you would engage in a
perjury trap no what are the every
confidence in Bob Muller one of the
things we've learned the Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh worked on your
team worked on this investigation of
President Bill Clinton he wrote and
suggested some very explicit salacious
questions should be asked of President
Clinton but you didn't agree to do that
why well we wanted to respect the
dignity
the presidency and I think that we did
that but we at the same time had to get
to the bottom of things so we asked all
the prosecutors what should we ask it
was a deliberative process and the rest
is unfolded that's what I talk about in
the book one of the other things you
talk about in the book as you say an
indulgent and prosperous nation readily
forgave Bill Clinton give me your
assessment of the nation and its moral
judgment it made on the president you
talk about prosperity yeah I think the
first of all the system did work our
system of checks and balances work that
is the president was held accountable he
in fact had to answer to articles of
impeachment but at the same time the
American people are very forgiving and
we also want stability and so one of the
messages of this book is be careful
about impeachment impeachment is hell
and putting the nation's through that
process is really quite wrenching
because one of the defense arguments
that you seem to be alluding here to is
there's a lot of people said look the
country is doing well the economy is
humming why are you gonna pick on this
president he's got the country going so
well and what that echo of that we here
with President Trump who's saying he
said quote they're not going to I don't
think Democrats will impeach me since
I'm doing such a good job
do you see parallels in that oh there
are many parallels because I do think
that in the 1990s as I recount in the
book which is called contempt and the
contempt is because a Bill Clinton
having been held in contempt by a
federal judge first time in only time
and hopefully it will be the only time
in American history so there are a
number of parallels and so we see that I
think history is teaching us the history
of the 90s is teaching us about 2018 but
do you to send a moral warning to the
country to say you know just cuz things
are going well doesn't mean you should
overlook these important questions about
the rule of law truth and absolutely if
we don't have the rule of law in the
country then we have not done what the
founding generation said we're here to
establish justice that's in the preamble
of the Constitution and justice means
the rule of law and that everyone is
accountable Monica Lewinsky has said the
release of the Starr report the 445 page
report was one of the worst days of her
life she wants an apology we apologize
to her no
I want because unfortunately the facts
are the facts and we were put in the
position that under the statute on which
I was appointed I had a duty I had a
responsibility I will say and I've said
it for many times I regret all the pain
that resulted to so many including to
the nation of course I regret that but
no I can't in conscience say to Monica
anything other than I'm sorry that the
whole thing happened the day that she
was questioned in a hotel room was
dubbed Operation prom night why was a
sting operation necessary it wasn't a
sting operation what it was was simply a
mechanism of trying to confirm what we
thought we knew and we did know it these
were in fact the facts and to give her
the opportunity to cooperate with the
investigation had she cooperated this
entire matter would have been wound up
in a matter of several weeks and the
nation would have been spared all this
so we treated her with dignity we
treated with the respect and said here
is the possibility you can cooperate
with the investigation which has been
authorized by the Attorney General and
was destined to be authorized with a
spectrum by the special division and now
please cooperate and let's get this over
with
can I ask about Ken Starr and what's
happened since the whole impeachment of
President Bill Clinton in your
investigation you went on to become the
president and Chancellor of Baylor
University but two years ago you left
for miss handling sexual assault claims
there was an independent investigation
of your role at Baylor which said that
you failed to take action to identify
and eliminate a potential hostile
environment should you have done more
well I disagree with that finding but I
accept the judgment the Board of Regents
that there needed to be a change in the
leadership and a sort of new day I cared
deeply and still do about the students I
continue to mentor and counsel students
at Baylor we love the students at Baylor
University I do think that the
University and I was responsible
ultimately for that failed with respect
to the early response how do we respond
to this but it was never brought to my
attention until then at the very end
when in fact
that I recommended the board that we
have the independent investigation I
accept that judgment we want the
students to do well University life
should be safe and all too frequently
it's not even at Baylor all right Ken
Starr thank you very much great having
you here thank you
contempt of a kind contempt a memoir of
the Clinton investigation goes on sale
tomorrow